areter vous avez indiqué vous même lors
de la session l'audition de thomas
bonheur que vous regardiez pas ses news
donc je me fie aux observateurs qui
regardent la chaîne pour moi c'est pas
une chaîne d'opinion g on part d'une
situation de 33 millions d'euros de
déficit en 2016 c'est ça la situation de
ces news pourquoi ces news est dans
cette situation parce qu'on a le record
du monde du 200 chaînes d'information
gratuites
avec un passage de lci en clair dont on
s'écrit pas complètement la nécessité
est derrière la chaine france info qui a
été créée quatre chaînes gratuites plus
toutes les chaînes où l'information est
reprise qui n'ont fait qu'aggraver le
déficit de cette chaîne 33 millions
d'euros - je je je vais revenir sur sur
mon parcours peut-être mais je suis pas
un idéologue je suis un gestionnaire je
pense que c'est pour ça que j'ai été
recruté par vincent bolloré
33 millions déficit c'est pas possible
c'est pas durable c'est pas pérenne on
parle de diversité on parle de
pluralisme si toutes les chaînes
d'information disparaît sous toutes les
chaînes d'informations privées on a un
problème
32 millions de pertes à l'époque pour
lci donc je dirais la situation est de
même nature notre réflexion et comment
est-ce qu'on résorber ce déficit est le
sujet pour nous c'est de se différencier
sur un marché qui est pléthorique
le sujet l'analyse qu'on fait c'est con
à bfm qui est sur un positionnement de
breaking news qu'on n'a pas la capacité
de suivre parce qu'il est très coûteux
et vous savez bfm et là la seule un chat
d'informations privées rentable
et ils font un travail remarquable j'ai
absolument pas de critiques à apporter à
cette chaîne et nous notre souhait c'est
de nous différencier et donc on parle
dans une logique de durée d'ecoute en
disant on va pas pouvoir faire du
breaking news et d'informations brutes
aussi aussi aussi aussi clairement que
le fai bfm et donc on va aller dans une
durée d'ecoute dans une logique de durée
d'ecoute pour que les téléspectateurs
restent davantage et pour générer du
revenu publicitaire et donc à partir de
là on part sur une notion de débat qui
est la réalité du positionnement
éditorial aujourd'hui vous vous dites
chaînes d'opinion moi je dis non donc je
réponds clairement à votre à votre
question c'est une chaîne de débats où
toutes les opinions à votre convocation
à s'exprimer c'est ça la réalité et
c'est bien pour ça que le succès de ces
news est arrivé parce que il ya des
opinions qui se sont retrouvés sur cette
chaîne parce qu'elles étaient exprimées
et potentiellement ne l'était pas
ailleurs quand vous avez un
positionnement sur la durée avec des
opinions qui sont toutes les opinions
qui sont représentés à l'antenne et ben
vous avez des téléspectateurs qui ne les
entends n'est pas et qui tout d'un coup
se retrouvent
[Musique]